the mathematics of the correlation
coefficients are important but it is
perhaps more important to be able to
interpret it correctly a correlation
coefficient of let's say 0.5 tells us
that something interesting is going on
as far as the relation of x and y is
concerned but what exactly it tells us
that the two random variables are
associated in some sense but this is
often misinterpreted to mean that there
is a causal relation between the two but
this is wrong a large correlation
coefficient in general does not indicate
that there is a causal relation between
the random variables as an example
suppose that X somehow quantifies the
mathematical aptitude of a person and
why somehow quantifies the musical
ability of a person in general it has
been found that mathematical updated and
musical ability are correlated people
who score high on one will score high on
the other and as well is the causal
relation if you study math a lot and you
become very good at math does it mean
that you will become a better musician
not necessarily or if you practice the
violin day in and day out does this mean
that you will score better in the math
exam again not necessarily perhaps what
is going on is that there is a certain
feature of the human brain and when that
feature is well-developed then that
feature helps both in math and in
musical ability and this is a typical
situation of how a correlation
coefficient may arise that is often a
correlation coefficient that significant
reflects that the reason underlying
common but perhaps hidden factor that
affects both of the random variables x
and y let us go through a simple
numerical example that models the
situation of this kind suppose that Z V
and W are independent random variables
and that we have two more random
variables defined by these relations
notice that there is no direct influence
from X to Y or from
I 2x but on the other hand there is a
common underlying factor this random
variable Z that affects both x and y
because of this we expect that x and y
will somehow have some kind of relation
or association between them and we would
like to measure the strength of that
association the way to measure it will
be in terms of the correlation
coefficient which we will now proceed to
compute to have a complete example in
our hands and in order to also keep
things simple let us assume that the
basic underlying random variable Z V and
W all have zero means and unit variances
and now let us take the definition of
the correlation coefficient and start
calculating let us look at the variance
of X because X is the sum of two
independent random variables it's
variance is going to be the sum of those
variances and we have assumed that each
one of those variances is equal to 1 so
the variance of X is equal to 2 and that
implies that the standard deviation of X
is equal to the square root of 2 by a
similar argument the standard deviation
of Y is also equal to the square root of
2 now let us look at the covariance
between x and y because x and y have
zero means the covariance is just the
expected value of the product of the two
random variables and using the
definition of what these two random
variables are it's this particular
product here we expand the product into
a sum of four terms and take the
expected value of each one of the four
terms
which leaves us with this particular
expression here now Z has zero mean and
unit variance therefore the expected
value of Z squared is equal to one how
about the next term V and Z are
independent so the expected value of the
product is the product of the expected
values but the expected values are 0 so
this term is 0
and with a similar argument the other
terms are 0 as well so the covariance is
equal to 1 and from this we can conclude
our calculation and write that the
correlation coefficient between X and Y
is equal to 1 divided by the square root
of 2 times square root of 2 which is 1/2
this example also serves to give you a
rough idea of what it may mean to have a
correlation coefficient of 1/2 it means
that the two random variables have some
common elements and they also have some
idiosyncratic elements and these two
elements are roughly equal in weight if
V and W were completely absent the
correlation coefficient would have been
1 if on the other hand V and W had a
huge variance so as to completely hide
the effect of Z then the value of the
correlation coefficient would have been
much much smaller perhaps closer to 0
and in the extreme case of course where
Z is completely absent then x and y are
independent and we get the correlation
coefficient of 0